hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my Twitter followers who was
asking about working hard so the
question was should I work hard or rely
on talent so thanks for the question
honestly I don't see why you couldn't do
both I try to work hard and rely on your
talent and I think we're that will come
from is really doing something that
you're passionate excited about so if
you're running the business that really
gets you going that you know you're
really helping a lot of people with and
you you know have a unbridled enthusiasm
for then you're going to be really
talented at it because you're going to
you know love what you do you're going
to try to research all the ways to get
better and provide more value to your
customers and you're going to work hard
again because you love what you're doing
so i think the the answer is both you
know work hard and rely on your talent
but it all starts you know maybe a step
before that and trying to do something
that you're really passionate excited
about so that you don't have to motivate
yourself every day to kind of keep going
you're doing it because you you know
you're doing something good for the
world and you're having a lot of fun and
it's exciting do it in the process so
hopefully that will give you the
motivation you need to work hard and use
your talents as well so hopefully that
answers your question after those are
you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up it makes you
want to do more these videos for you and
if you have a question or you want to
comment on this video feel free to leave
it in the section below I always read
them and I always appreciate them so
thank you and you'll see you on the next
episode
you